there's mounting international concern
over tens of thousands of russian troops
dug in along the border with ukraine
russia and nato have traded warnings
each side claims it's being threatened
by the other but in the west one
question dominates what will vladimir
putin do next
we talked this week to a respected
foreign policy analyst in moscow fyodor
lukianov has the west misunderstood
russia's position and just how dangerous
is the current situation is it dangerous
yes of course it's risky but this is a
high stake game
and
i'm absolutely sure that mr putin as we
know him well we know him for pretty
pretty many years already
he is a he is not a gambler so how did
we get to this point and where do we go
from here and what about putin's
intentions at home cracking down on
opposition and closing the country's
oldest civil rights group
all this and more on conflict zone
[Music]
fjorda lukianov welcome to conflict zone
hello
in your opinion how likely is russia to
launch a fresh incursion into ukraine
in my opinion it's totally unlikely
because it's not in the russian agenda
never was never could be
not at this point certainly i don't know
how things will develop in the future
because the ukrainian issue
as an international problem is a problem
of russian political development
does exist of course
but for now i don't see any chance
for that to happen
so the option isn't even on the table at
the moment as far as you're concerned
i don't mean the the option is on the
table at the moment
i mean that the problem does exist
and what russia is trying to achieve now
it's actually to postpone this problem
maybe in the best case to remove it for
the future
but
means used now
are so to say taken from the classical
diplomacy when you need some kind of
demonstration in order to get attention
of your
counterparts to launch a sensible and
substantial conversation
so that's the whole rationale for the
steady buildup of forces around ukraine
on land sea and air hundred thousand
soldiers on russia's border with ukraine
it's all just attention seeking is it
uh
it's
mostly about uh to create a situation
when uh americans uh
the nato at large but in particular
americans
uh
would understand
that there is an issue in europe which
should be addressed and this is not a
ukrainian issue this is an issue about
how european security has been arranged
after the cold war
and this is a very complicated thing
so russia tried to
erase this question many many times
before
including in 90s especially in 2000s and
2010s
but the problem was that no one even
paid attention no one listened to that
and the ideas which russia tried to
promote were not just rejected they were
simply ignored and unfortunately the end
of the day russian leadership as i uh
read it
understood that the only way to get
attention to launch a discussion is to
demonstrate force and since uh the west
is
very much obsessed with ukraine in
particular so ukraine in this regard
sorry to say it but is rather
instrumental so they wanted to to get to
the west's attention they drew up a list
of demands to nato which they knew would
be unacceptable and then threatened dire
and unspeakable consequences if nato
turned them down which of course it did
so what was that all about creating a
pretext for war
well it's not a creating a pretext for
war
it's something else because you say that
those demands are unacceptable which i
agree
and of course in the format as they were
put on the table i cannot imagine any
kind of uh agreement from the nato side
from the american side
but look at what happened since those
demands were uh raised and were
formulated
already now despite the fact that the
severe uh political crisis and security
affairs crisis is in place in europe
already now we have uh us acceptance and
u.s interest to discuss issues which
americans flatly rejected two or three
months ago i mean those technical
military technical uh details to say so
about uh security about placement of
armament and the units in eastern europe
so conventional arms control and so on
so this is just after uh the uh
those demands were put so of course this
diplomatic process continues and we see
that
despite all hysteria in the west and
despite all very firm positions declared
but no one wants to shoot shoot the door
shut the door and
i think we are on the way to something
new
it will not happen immediately of course
assuming that the talks continue between
moscow and washington how much progress
can they actually make
given that russia is demanding a right
of veto that it doesn't have and knows
it doesn't have how far can they go
uh
so far there are no negotiations
actually
so far we see
diplomatic
maneuvering
around the crisis uh in a classical
style so we can remember something like
this both from the cold war time and
even earlier from the
earlier periods of diplomacy classical
diplomacy
i don't think we are there yet so the
real negotiations uh about the substance
i mean security arrangements in europe
and eastern europe but larger in europe
uh uh
per se uh will probably start
later and before it
will arrive
we will see more of uh demonstrations
including uh from the russian side now
for example in belarus a big military
exercise will be conducted in february
it's not to launch a war of course but
it's to demonstrate uh
commitment so to say to defend its
interest
at the same time i see that on the both
sides diplomats
they
have very uh
strong and very firm
instructions so far not to engage in any
any talks about compromises but they
accumulate uh possibilities and
uh after a while certainly we will start
substantial talk it will be not the talk
about
uh the this those demands exactly but
about how to change the basic principles
of european uh security arrangements as
they emerged 1990 1991
i
you say as they emerged at that time how
much of this goes back to
uh the russian claim that
nato made a promise about not expanding
eastwards
and then broke it that's not borne out
by the facts is
it uh
you know in russia there is absolute
axiom so everybody knows and that was
also
documented uh not in a written
obligation of course but
we have transcripts from negotiations at
that time
that
u.s representatives and german
representatives uh promised mr gorbachev
that
nato that
unified germany's nato membership will
not be a model for the future expansion
uh and in this regard uh this uh
this those reminiscents
this memory uh spoils uh
uh the relationship now and the russian
side it's very important but at the same
time
i don't believe it didn't happen that
way did it i mean in in a 2014 interview
gorbachev himself said the topic of nato
expansion was not discussed at all and
it wasn't brought up in those years i
say this with full responsibility not a
single east european leader raised the
issue not even after the warsaw pact
ceased to exist in 1991.
that should have ended the matter
shouldn't it yes absolutely that's why i
also believe that this discussion is
senseless i think you can find a lot of
references and the literature is very
rich now uh discussing what was said
exactly what was promised what was not
promised
and those words by uh secretary baker no
inch eastwards they are well known but
again it doesn't matter anymore it's
psychologically important but it's not
important in terms of real politics in
terms of real politics one thing is
essential
uh the european security arrangements
as they uh were formulated after at the
end of cold war and after collapse of
the soviet union were de facto based on
on the phenomenon of nato as the key
euro
nato and the euro-atlantic institutions
as key elements as the base as the core
for european security which meant the
more nato the more security
and this principle was developed since
that pretty uh linearly pretty
consequently
russia
initially soviet union then russia
without big enthusiasm accepted that at
the beginning
but later on uh changed mind
significantly and starting from 1990s
russian establishment and russian
leadership were were very much concerned
and uh unhappy with nato expansion
and claimed this uh even boris yeltsin
but especially vladimir putin and his
entourage they made it many many times
uh it didn't help so we see that nate
yeah but um the fact is that if you take
ukraine moscow's own actions have done
far more to push ukrainian towards nato
than anything the alliance did haven't
they why doesn't the kremlin realize
that up until russia invaded crimea in
2014 there was very little appetite
among ukrainians for joining the
alliance in 2013 less than 20 percent of
the country supported membership today
it's almost 60 so the kremlin shot
itself in the foot didn't it
yeah of course situation since uh 2014
uh
deteriorated significantly
but uh frankly i don't believe that
international big international issue
issues uh especially those uh referred
to geopolitics and international
security big scale international
security should be decided based on
opinion polls which are changing quite
frequently
so
what happened 2014 was not the beginning
of the process that was a
an important benchmark of the process
which as i uh referred earlier started
immediately after the cold war the idea
that nature is available for everybody
and nature is uh uh equal to european
security that created situation which at
the end of the day led to the to the
performance we have now
so what has nato done in the last year
or so that has brought this crisis to a
head
uh you mean uh this particular crisis
the crisis around uh around russia
yeah uh
nato nato uh or rather uh i don't
believe we should speak about nato
because nato is just a bureaucratic
organization but particular members
which play uh most important role
decisive role
with regard to ukrainian particularly of
course we see increase of military
cooperation military
delivery to ukraine from particular nato
members be turkey be it uh united states
be the uk
and the military capacity of ukraine is
increasing and of course russian
military who are responsible for
those issues they they take into take
into account
another thing which uh has not to do
with ukraine but i think has
a lot to do with the bigger picture
is that uh
in 2021
two things happened which demonstrated
uh that nature
inside nature the situation is actually
slightly different than
nato officials and nato bureaucracy
would love to
uh to demonstrate i mean afghanistan and
uh creation of this ocus grouping uh
when united states basically decided for
themselves what to do same in
afghanistan and i think both of those
events brought russian leadership to
conclusion that this is right time to
start to discuss with americans how to
probably transform the role of nato and
european security why because why
because because america because america
started to look weak in their eyes is
that it they thought they could apply
more pressure now
no no
no no no it's not about weakness it's
about priorities america is strong and i
think no one denies that
but priorities are changing and the nato
as alliance is obviously less
prioritized for the us now in the era of
a big confrontation with china
which means that uh probably the general
basic view on how to arrange european
security and international security
international security might change it's
not about weakness at all what if moscow
doesn't get the security guarantees or
the level of confidence from
eventual negotiations with america that
it's it's looking for
what what would it settle for let's
start by asking that question in
relation to ukraine what would it settle
for a continuation of the status quo
where
nobody actually advances
ukraine's membership of nato that it's
just parked somewhere and left and
nothing more happens would moscow settle
for that
you know that's a very interesting
mismatch and perceptions in the west and
here because everything even from our
conversation everything we hear from the
west is that this is ukrainian crisis
crisis around ukraine
uh so the the ukrainian issue is central
to this and russian ambitions according
to the western calculations are about to
to do something with ukraine
here is different here it is seen as
as a general uh
uh payback so to say for 30-plus years
of
development uh in europe and around
europe
uh and an attempt to uh renegotiate
even using demonstration of force and
even using
unconventional means like this
those demands
renegotiate the principles
and to your question i don't believe
that at the end of the day it might end
with nothing because
russia
put the question very very uh strongly
and very boldly
so in one or another form it will be
negotiations i'm sure
certainly uh
no one in moscow expects to get legally
binding guarantees at as it is claimed
this is a
well-known uh
initial position it's in diplomacy the
normal normal phenomenon
but
we see already now that uh debating the
west is starting to change not about
ukraine but about the principle whether
it's so important to the west to keep
nato's
doors uh open as it is as it was
is it really worth uh uh doing
and we see that american diplomacy uh if
we go beyond rhetoric is actually much
more flexible
uh as russian is
so i i guess that we will uh
relatively soon not immediately but
relatively soon arrive to the
substantial negotiation which will be
based then it will be based on
compromises not yet but mr lukianov it's
a dangerous game isn't it ramping up the
tension between two nuclear-armed
superpowers it's easy to misread signals
jump to the wrong conclusions is this
the act of a responsible leader to
create and maintain tension and he seems
to be enjoying the tension in november
he said the pressure on the west was
working this is vladimir putin our
recent warnings have been heard and the
effect is noticeable tensions have risen
russia should maintain the tensions as
long as possible is that really a
responsible act from a responsible
leader
this is
a way
which we
so to say uh forgot during last uh
decades
when we had an absolute uh dominance of
the united states and and its allies in
international affairs
so at that period it was impossible to
act like this obviously
but if we look at the history of
international relations it's not unique
at all so it's rather a
normal element of hard bargaining
and if we uh look at the core of the
substance so not just
means process or ukrainian situation but
this is an attempt to revise and to
correct
international system which is not
satisfactory for uh some of very
powerful actors okay previously it
happened only
moscow talks a lot about threats from
the west
and i'm asking what kind of threats
because mr putin's been telling the
world for years that the west is in
decline it's decadent it's weak
liberalism its core ideology is in his
words obsolete
if the west's in that much trouble what
kind of danger could it possibly pose to
russia the arguments don't add up do
they
you know
this discussion about liberal is
non-liberalism this is another thing uh
i think it's uh a little bit more
philosophical and
when decisions about uh
geopolitical moves are being taken
they they they are simpler than this
very sophisticated uh argumentation
but uh
uh the the weakness uh
okay the west is of course not as uh
powerful as it used to be 25 years ago
no doubt about that
but uh the threat the military danger or
the general danger
uh
again i just can remind you that uh mr
putin and other russian officials they
keep saying they kept saying that since
very very long time
but no one at all wanted to listen to
that and they just said oh come on
that's some russian russian problems we
we should not take much
much attention to that so and
unfortunately yes uh what putin said
publicly openly in november that we need
increased pressure to achieve some kind
of interest of our counterparts to
listen to our demands that's unusual i
agree
but
that is a product of very long very
fruitless attempts
to get it in a different way is it
dangerous yes of course it's risky but
this is a high stake games and
i'm absolutely sure that mr putin as we
know him when we know him for pretty
pretty many years already
he is he's not a gambler he's a very
calculated player and he's very much
aware about all dangers which you refer
to about the relationship between
nuclear superpowers very much
in the past few weeks russia has been
lecturing the west a lot about not
respecting the treaties it signed but
its own actions have shown the kremlin
feels totally free to violate written
commitments and pledges at will
look no further than the invasion and
occupation of part of georgia in 2008
the seizure and annexation of crimea in
2014 in violation of the nato-russia
founding act plenty of other agreements
does the kremlin believe that that's all
been forgiven and forgotten
uh it's not about forgiveness it's not
about to forge
to to forget it's something else and i
think exactly uh what you say is very
important because
the
number of violations of written or
oral agreements reached after the cold
war on both sides
demonstrate one simple thing
that the system as it emerged
did not guarantee
that security can be maintained to
agreements
and it should be uh changed and should
be adapted to the
power balance to something to to
circumstances which are objective
otherwise we will continue in this way
to to blame each other for uh who
violated what and to be absolutely sure
that our uh our truth is the only one
and we need to get it through uh there
is another way to try to as as it
happened before uh through diplomacy in
um
very
turbulent times in mankind's history uh
to try to sit down
and to understand why it happened and
maybe something went wrong went wrong
after the cold war when the west was
totally euphoric and russia was
depressed
has something gone badly wrong in russia
because the crisis at the moment goes
hand in hand with what the economist
magazine called last november a new era
of russian repression the russian civil
rights group memorial estimated the
number of political prisoners in russia
at around 450 comparable to the soviet
union in the 1980s at least it did until
mr putin shut the organization down in
december is the world right to conclude
that this signals an increasingly
authoritarian rule from the kremlin now
the rule in russia is changing but of
course i would not uh
exaggerate that but i don't belong to
those who are happy about this
development so personally i think it's
it's it's a wrong wrong direction which
should be should be changed and will be
changed inevitably after a while
the question is different uh do
we need
to focus on that
and the domestic development in russia
or in china or in the united states
where
wherever
in order to try to achieve more balanced
international system
so after the cold war that was an idea
that there are universal values which
should be implemented everywhere and
that will be guaranteed for
more or less stable peace and security
it didn't work as we as we see support
probably now we should separate a little
bit between domestic development in
particular countries and the
international arrangements which should
be achieved
uh whatever happens inside those
countries
fjordo lukianov it's been good to have
you on conflict zone thank you very much
for your time
thank you
thank you
so
you